look
you why who thinks he's smarter than you
why because he's smarter than you
this is just a sponsor
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shock man
[Music]
[Music]
tyranny
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship d-banking
arrest tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser he's a disgrace
and he's with his christ
and he's with his christ and he's with
his christ
[Music]
mangoes my bags are mangoes
[Music]
i love mangoes too nine
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures like
three boxes
that's it
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
she's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
he's not a knight at the round table
that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Music]
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
trump was doing this with his personal
toilet
toilets
and showers elements of bathrooms
10 times 15 times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would
[Music]
big
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome everybody it is day one of
cpac texas 2022
proceedings are underway and there's a
lot of wacky stuff coming up today so
i'm glad that you're with us right now
the schlapp twins i'm sorry not the then
not the schlep twins these their husband
and wife i guess the schlapps i guess
we're calling them matt and mercedes are
speaking to radical
repugnant
reactionary retrograde
rancid republican governor greg abbott
and i guess soon sarah palin is going to
be joining them and then in about 15
minutes the hungarian president victor
orban and an extremist nationalist is
expected to take the stage
which is
quite crazy i mean as if we don't have
enough authoritarian lunatics here
we've got to go and bring them from
eastern europe to speak
to american right-wing clowns so it's
going to be quite a day quite a day and
we're monitoring a number of different
feeds we have
so many different things going on here
and it's all
uh
it all is what it is i mean it's this is
the i continue to uh
have extreme levels of concern
for
this
a right-wing movement that
doesn't even pretend to care about
policy they just want to care about
owning the libs and being as extremely
authoritarian as they can and also in
going against their own stated
principles when the principles aren't
convenient we're for small government
except regulate twitter
and don't allow gay marriage and don't
allow abortion and
right i mean so uh it it's r it's quite
a scene quite a scene and we have so
many different things happening here uh
we have about two dozen unbanned
requests on twitch
i have an incredible kim iverson
compilation we have new giga cringe from
joseph r rogan ii
um
what else do i we we're going to look at
the we have elements from alex jones
pac-man's a loser oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad right and then in addition to
that
we may be on the precipice of a number
of consecutive streams
including tomorrow we might get two
streams cpac day two
and the scrumps rally at night and then
saturday is the main event of cpac at
which
the former the failed former president
donald trump will actually be speaking
so we may be looking at
four streams in three days just to get a
sense of the
tone and tenor of cpac let's listen but
then i have so many things and we're
gonna look at a bunch of stuff between
now and when victor orban speaks
and he
said
that parents don't have a right to know
this audio level is is criminal let me
adjust it
in our classroom
now
as i said terry mcauliffe is retired i
think beta o'rourke might have hired him
robert francis to be his campaign
manager because
is out there saying what are parents
doing intervening in the education of
their children they have numbers this is
a very whiny delivery you mentioned one
of the elements
and that is transparency elementary
bathrooms have every right to know
exactly all of the materials that their
children are being taught we we learned
that
[Applause]
we learned that during we can't teach
transgender nobody knows what that means
but you certainly can't do it me for the
first time got to see that in fact our
students and even in texas
were being taught critical race theory
and so i would love for greg abbott to
ever have to explain what critical race
theory is it's that white people should
hate themselves
wow greg that's an incredible analysis
by the way
we are seven percent from completing our
first level five hype train on twitch in
a very long time beautiful children over
there
well some of it there's additional
children out there three
one i didn't mean so here's a point with
them here's some children you
you love your children
more than any government employee ever
can
you have the right to be the decision
maker for the health care and
educational decisions for your child
you should have the right to choose the
school that is best for your child as
opposed to government mandating what
school your child should attend
right
okay
governor your crowd really riled up huh
an electric speaker growing hispanic
community here in texas and it just we
saw the recent win of congresswoman
flores which was a huge success
she's going to be here yes and we've
seen other candidates that the new york
times now calls the far right latina it
looks almost empty did you see that shot
of the crowd there
first
republican conservative leaders out
there who simply love america they love
their faith all right so you get to say
we're we're really standing by for
victor orban and then he'll be followed
up actually we have the agenda sean
hannity is speaking today it's going to
be a completely delusional day
and uh i am uh looking looking forward
to it
very much because of how insane it's
going to be all right let's get to a
couple of different things here i do
want to say thank you to two very
special people here at the top caleb
rose
and ryan carpenter both signing up for
memberships on my website joinpakman.com
also want to say thanks to everybody who
has supported on twitch in the last few
minutes and this includes
uh polo dal
dirt knap life is good rated roy richie
danv with a gift and a subscription your
old shoes gifted five putting us at 12.
crowbar stuck a duck and nappa skip dog
have signed up putting us at 15 and then
we've got billy carpenter blueberry babe
philly phillip skittle stew and badness
immediately pushing us to 22
and when you add in flea girl and dustin
d
we're already at 24 at this very nascent
stage of today's stream
all right let's look at a couple
different things here
um and there's so much
this is kind of funny the other day i
talked about kim iverson
and we we tried to look at a clip of her
talking about something about trans and
it was so boring that i had to bail and
our friend independent nn put together
this thing for us oh speaking of uh
speaking of kim iverson
do you not think that there is an
increase in children younger that they
feel like they're the other gender i
mean are we seeing an increase in that
of
of because it's a phase i mean i do i do
think that teenagers go through faith
why is kim iverson so annoying like i
just don't care what you know i was like
okay you have terrible ideas about
everything why would anyone listen to
you too much more research on that to
know that i think tends to be the fad of
the era that is that is how it is it
doesn't diminish or or you know it
doesn't diminish the fact that latching
on to exists and exist you know they're
saying oh okay well that's me now that's
what i feel you are a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ]
this is quite a compilation you know
certainly i guess there would be
you know i'm feeling a certain way is
there an increase of that what is she
talking about something because they're
more the society's more open
i'm pretty sure you know that thing
about how like if you put a thousand
monkeys in front of a thousand
typewriters eventually they'd write
macbeth
i think that that was how this
diatribe was generated it's random
monkeys typing words she used a random
word generator to describe it to create
it
i mean i guess i don't know how much
more there is really to say about it
but there's uh kim iverson with
opinions about trans i mean there she's
entitled to her opinions and
i don't even know what else to say about
it
[Music]
all right so pretty nicely done by our
friend independent nn there i can
absolutely get behind that
uh okay so a lot of very strange things
happening here we have a different
stream of uh cpac and we're gonna keep
an eye on that very very closely thank
you to shannon mcintyre for signing up
at joinpakman.com very much appreciate
that your new member number 25 today
also cash money rash
it's my hipaa
glitteriest ladydread signing up via
twitch putting us at 28. greg abbott
continues to use words to try to
communicate with language
and uh
somebody in the room at least seems to
be liking it for being here cpac keep up
the good work all right we'll get it
done
thank you all very much
really just an electric and
inspirational atmosphere at cpac and
greg abbott hard to imagine a more high
energy speaker than him
super chat's coming in
uh none right now but that's okay we're
tracking all of it very very closely
fire pelosi save america the theme of
this year's cpac as you can see there
and now we go into the my coffee element
of cpac i get products all the time from
entrepreneurs for my new platform
mystore.com oh my god and when i tried
my copy for the first time i was blown
away it is the best coffee i've ever had
in my life i spent the last four months
doing my due diligence are we going to
learn more about this at the savosium
every step from the fields to the cup to
ensure the best quality coffee you're
ever going to have it starts with the
beans that are grown in honduras
honduras is volcanic honduras
you can grow beans in america
shouldn't you be getting the beans in
hawaii i mean if this is all about
america why is honduras that sounds
extremely un-american the coffee
industry and after that it goes into
production which is all done right here
in the usa
it's like you're getting that small bad
specialty coffee but delivered right to
your front door so go to my this is like
a low rent billy mays you know what i
mean like it's just not working it's not
working all right so that's what they've
got going on there and they're we're
going to be back with all of it very
soon thanks to trish the dish and
erroneous as well as decomposing diva
brain matter and j.p de beast already
exists for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 33. all
right next element here let's go to joe
rogan
uh joe rogan
is now mad about
something
something about the world economic forum
and um
electric vehicles
let's look at a couple super chats
before we go and who do you think will
win the republican arizona governor's
race i i don't know i mean they're
counting i have no idea they're counting
ballots we have to wait and see
republicans sure hate when you do agree
with their ideas but the people of
kansas has spoken all right listen to
this put out on july 18th which three
circular economy approaches to reduce
demand for critical metals oh wow and
this is who put this out that this is on
the world world economic forum
shifting from fossil fuels to renewables
requires huge amounts of critical metals
which is true recycling alone won't be
enough to sustain them oh i get it they
they [ __ ] played the old switcheroo
on us you got to get an electric car so
actually yeah now that we've got you off
the fossil fuels that's not enough dude
not even no you don't need to uh oh so
the idea is there's like some conspiracy
here cycling is not going to be enough
to sustain the amount of materials
needed so we need to increase sharing
reuse
and
a preference for longevity to reduce
demand what does that even mean what
that let me explain joe what that means
we should prefer products that last a
long time
so you don't have to replace them
frequently
it's not
particularly nefarious we should have a
prep so it's sort of like
you know
when i bought my espresso machine which
by the way is now in legal hell we're
doing a class action lawsuit against all
machines when i bought my espresso
machine in 2015 that's seven years ago
i could have gone with a two hundred
dollar machine
and it probably would have had to have
been replaced already but instead
i went with a beautiful
six hundred and fifty dollar machine
which is made from metal
and other elements
and it is still working beautifully
it's now tied up in court i haven't seen
i haven't seen him my i could refer to
my espresso machine as him i haven't
seen him in months because he's tied up
in legal hell but the machine is still
going strong that's it's a preference
towards quality
so that i don't end up buying three
machines and two end up flush down the
toilet not particularly nefarious
interpret that please
who's going to own the ubers what need
to increase sharing
reuse and a preference for longevity to
reduce demand what does that mean
why is that so ambiguous
why is it so confusing would be a better
question at reducing sharing i get
reusing but a preference for longevity
yes
prefer items that last longer
reduce the man
reduce demand what does that mean yeah
what it means is as follows
my demand for espresso machines is lower
if my one machine lasts a long time
if i am committed to having an espresso
machine
if it breaks now i demand a new machine
and by demand i don't mean i show up and
go
let me speak to the manager i i mean i
demand it economically speaking i'm in
the market for a machine
if i have one that has more longevity
i'm reducing my demand for new machines
because i've got a working machine
do you know what that means don't buy
new cars a lot but i'm left off
preference for longevity so preferring
older cars is that what's preferred no
preferring cars that last a long time i
own it longer overall like cuba
like oh my god oh god
like cuba communist cuba you know
they have the dopamine you can't learn
anything that's basically what they're
saying they buy our [ __ ] they have cars
they have cars in cuba they have dope
old car i cannot believe this is
happening
i cannot believe this is happening
preferring better quality stuff means we
will be like cuba
which i love old cars oh my god have you
ever seen like those photographs of
because what they've done is they've
maintained them and taken care of them
and like re you know like re-fixed them
and refinished them they're [ __ ]
amazing yeah oh my god and then he's
like it's actually pretty cool
when you take care of stuff it that's
that is something else guys
that is really really really something
else wow
wow
uh
yeah uh i i would love to go back on
with rogan and just talk about this
stuff be like joe were you really that
confused by like hey we should prefer
stuff that lasts a long time because
it's just like better i'd rather get one
good pair of boots than buy a new pair
of boots every year and also that keeps
boots out of landfills like it's just
it's not complicated
it's not complicated
uh okay
thanks to fat billy from philly as well
as fluid
shoplifting empath and fat comrade for
the twitch prime subscriptions putting
us at 37. let me announce by the way we
have just made an incredible upgrade to
the david pakman show membership program
instead now
of us having a barely functioning audio
podcast for our members we have a new
system it is uh generating a unique
podcast feed url for every member it's
self-service you want to put the podcast
feed in any app or get episodes emailed
to you daily or use a just watch in a
browser whatever we have a new system
i believe that this probably doubles or
triples the value of our memberships but
we are not increasing the prices
whatsoever and in fact if you use the
coupon code indict you will get a
criminal a criminal discount off of the
cost of memberships and it is truly
something else i hope you will avail
yourself of that
let's look at some other super chats
here david tell charles booker to make
an ad about rand paul's decision on the
packed act please
uh i'm not in touch with charles booker
but if i have the opportunity i would
absolutely talk to him about
that constantly making up conspiracies
probably makes them feel so smart and
special ooh that that's aggressive
that's uh that that's pretty damn
aggressive
i don't know if we want to go in that
direction right now
necessarily let's see what else we have
here as we are waiting for more things
oh dave rubin
explained the ideal family and i guess
the host got really confused by it this
should be interesting a family generally
is a father and a mother and then
children um are there way that is the
norm that is the norm and i would say in
some ways this is going to sound a
little bit weird for a certain amount of
people but that is that is sort of the
ideal but in the world not everything is
always the ideal so in in the family
that we are going to raise we're
obviously going to have two fathers
however that is not me saying oh women
are not important or that there is no
difference between men and women or
anything like that and it will look will
it look different than the traditional
family yes but how many people
do the traditional family truly write
with the best of the best of the mother
and the father and don't do anything to
screw up their kids psychologically this
is weird ruben is like justifying his
own gay parenthood
by saying lots of straight couples are
bad at parenting too
it's a strange
[Music]
line of reasoning or physically or
anything else so so i think you can say
that oh there is the norm and the ideal
and then there are things around that
and approximate to it that are pretty
good too and the best that i can do is
do the best that i can right ruben's
saying i will be providing what is a
subpar parenting situation because
there's no mother
but it will be equivalent to a lot of
heterosexual subpar parenting as well
that's what i'm hearing here to make
something good what i um hear from your
things right now is that
on the ideal you would prefer that your
children will be heterosexual extra
sexual and to
live in the classic
ideal family men and women well i i
wouldn't prefer
well that's not exactly what i'm saying
i don't know that i would prefer that
they would be i would well you're it's
kind of what he's saying he's kind of
saying
it would be best for people to be
heterosexual and that way they can be
heterosexual parents and the the host is
like kind of rightly pointing that out
and reuben's like well i don't know
about prefer
prefer
i would prefer that they
that i am able they can be gay as long
as they're straight parents which is the
best thing people to raise two children
who are functional adults who
uh have an understanding of the way the
world works and can find some meaning in
their lives and live a life that's
important to them if ultimately
uh they both turn out to be straight
that's fantastic if one of them turns
out to be gay that's fine too
but it's fine too is different than
fantastic
man that this is weird huh
not if it would happen you would of
course you would embrace them if they
were gay like
of course but this is not a question
yeah the question is what do you think
the ideal that you would um
teach or not teach but want your
children to be yeah
it's i guess we're getting hung up maybe
a little bit on the word want not really
no
i would understand in re in the the
reality of reality is that the life that
life would be sort of the easiest
supposedly although i don't think life
is necessarily supposed to be easy
oh my god
that is a word salad if i have ever seen
one oh my goodness
if i am correct
lone star state means
that independence freedom and
sovereignty are the dearest values so
this is the extreme right-wing
nationalist president of hungary victor
orban
and this is really scary stuff
then we have something in common
even in
hungary is over
5 000 miles from dallas
my country
hungary
is the lone star state of europe oh god
that's bad
you don't want that
the main difference between our
countries is that unfortunately
the ewing oil company is not paying
corporate income tax in budapest
but
independence freedom and sovereignty
is what we hungarians fought for in the
last
500 years yikes we vote for christianity
in the middle
and modern ages
and we fought for christian democracy
in the 20th century
and continue to fight to this day
we are a nation of 15 million
in the heart of europe
with a unique language
pope francis
once told me that hungary involves the
official language in heaven
because it takes an eternity to learn
is just a slight exaggeration
that's probably enough to know about
hungary
yeah as for myself
he smartly identifies that the cpap
crowd
doesn't give to you no what's about
hungary
um
i am also
the longest serving prime minister in
europe
the only anti-migration political leader
on our company very trumpian tooting his
own horn huh
and grandfather
to five grandchildren a leader of a
country
that is under the siege of progressive
liberals day by day
okay uh creating himself as being
endangered
anti-communist
old-fashioned freedom fighter
raised under communist rule
never dared to dream of
one of them is giving a speech at the
cpac here in the united states
in the land of the free oh god
but the spirit of liberty shines
brighter than at any other place on
earth
today this dream came true
and i can never be grateful enough
so i want to thank
the organizers for inviting me
especially matt schlapp
and thank you all for welcoming me the
most distinguished conservatives
of the united states want me to speak at
their conference
which is very scary during the last two
or three weeks
what you want to hear from me
i come
from a thousand-year-old country
with rich history
but let's be honest
hungary
is far from being a global superpower
true the us is a global superpower your
leaders should give an opening speech at
our conferences in hungary
there's an idea
and by by our leaders he means tucker
carlson who is spoken in hungary
inviting me
for example the leftist media
i can already see tomorrow's headlines
far right
european racist and anti-semite
strongman the trojan horse of putin
whole speech at conservative conference
pretty accurate that sounds pretty
accurate
but i'm not confused by his presence
here because he's exactly in line with
the authoritarian trumpist movement
there are many ideas
they know best how to write fake news
instead
i tell you the truth
in hungary we introduced a zero
tolerance policy on racism and
anti-semitism
so accusing us is fake news and those
who make these claims are simply idiots
they are
the industrial fake news corporation
progressive ngos
are probably confused as well
they are already busy writing their
so-called research papers
to inform americans how i destroyed
hungarian democracy
according to their research
i managed to ruin hungary's democracy in
2011
and then they say
i ruined it again in 2012
and then in 2013 and 14 and 15 and so on
each and every year
but how did i manage to destroy
something
that was already ruined
to answer to this question you have to
be a rabid liberal
finally
with my invitation
you have surprised the elite of
democratic party too
no we're not surprised i want to be
clear
we respect the government of the united
states we are guests here
and we need to behave decently
with the current administration as well
but
but there is another side of the coin
which i cannot ignore
your administration
has put europe
and especially brussels
under ideological pressure
this is not good for us it's bad the
obama administration
tried to force us to change the
fundamental law of hungary
and delete
christian and national values from it do
you get it
the leading power of the free world
wanted to force us to change our
constitution
according to a globalist liberal concept
uh oh here we go with globalist
this came as a surprise
and caused us a lot of pain
but we resisted this attempt
successfully since then
we are not the favorites of the american
democrats
they did not want me to be here and they
made every effort to drive a veg between
us
they hate me
and slander me and my country
as they hate you globally
and america you stand for we all know
how this works
progressive liberals didn't want me to
be here
because i can't think of anyone who
didn't want him to be there he has every
right to speak and he's invited it's
just a representation of the insane
circumstances
in which the republican party in the u.s
has become so authoritarian that they
have more in common with extreme
right-wing eastern european nationalists
than they do with you know whoever else
it's not oh ban him it's like wow it's
crazy that they're having him speak the
hungarians defeated communism
which was forced on us by soviet troops
and arms
it took a while
we began our fight
in 1956 and one in 1990
but we did it
our fathers fired the first shot
and we their sons won the war
we know what we have ronald reagan to
thank for
wow
does the crowd even understand what he's
talking about when he talks about
history
but communists are tough to beat
they rose from their ashes
came together with the liberals
and come back all around the world
stronger than ever
if somebody has doubts
whether progressive liberals and
communists are the same
just ask us hungarians
we fought them both and i can tell you
they are the same
so we had to defeat them again
and since 2010
we keep winning winning and winning
last time
last time
with the endorsement of donald trump
which we are grateful for
so much winning that we are just
scratching our heads
you know winning has become our daily
habit
but
but we know the old saying
yesterday's home runs
don't win today's games
i've been a member of common saying in
hungary
spending 16 years in opposition
and 16 years as prime minister
i learned that
a quitter never wins
and the winner never quits wow this is
the secret of our victories
you have to stand by your country in
good times and in bad times
dear friends
i'm here to tell you
we should share our experiences
i am here to tell you
that our values
the nation christian roots
and family
can be successful in the political
battlefield
even nowadays
when political life is ruled by liberal
hegemony
i am here to tell you
how we made these values successful
and mainstream in hungary
perhaps our story can help you
keep america great
here is our story
the key to our success story is
that when we fight
we give at least 100 percent
we tell the truth
and represent the truth even if
half the word attacks us for it
you cannot win half-heartedly
you either give everything you have got
and win
or play it safe
and lose
so first and foremost
we need to trust our judo christian
teachings yeah as i've said before when
these people say judeo-christian
they do it so that you don't think it's
just about christianity but most of them
are either
subtly or overtly anti-semitic and they
it's just a no on that that's just
another way that they sort of
distract from the fact that they are
christian nationalists if questions
migration gender and the clash of
civilizations don't worry
a christian politician cannot be racist
so we should never hesitate to heavily
challenge our opponents on these issues
be sure
christian values protect us from going
too far
moreover
we know
that in the end of our lives
the moment will come
when all our actions will be judged
so you can't do anything
you have limits did he just blow a snot
rocket
a man has got to know his limitations
but unfortunately
the left in politics
does not know any limitations
and my friends
as it happens
today's progressives try to separate
western civilization
from its christian roots once again
they are crossing a line that should
never be crossed
if you separate western civilization
from his judo-christian heritage
the worse things in history happen
let's be honest
the most available things in modern
history were carried out by people who
hated christianity
don't be afraid to call your enemies by
their name
you can't play safe
but they will never show mercy
consider for example george soros
as you call him here oh no
in hungary
in hungary we call him juribachi
which means uncle georgie here we go
the valciust and one of the most
talented hungarians on earth
just hint
be careful with talented hungarians uh i
know very careful with a crafty jewish
man that did guys this is crazy of the
things that we do
and he has an army at his service oh my
god money
ngos
universities
research institutions
and half the bureaucracy in brussels
he uses this army to force his will on
his opponents imagine thinking george
soros is the big global problem to bring
up values dear to all of us
led to the horrors of the 20th century
but the case is exactly the opposite
our values save us
from repeating history's mistake by the
way this guy has a zero tolerance policy
for anti-semitism of any kind
some western states in continental
europe
abandoned their christian values
and today's progressives are planning to
do the same
they want to give up on western values
and create a new word a post-western
word
who is going to stop them if we don't
dear friends
i have also learned
that in order to win
it is not enough to know what you are
fighting for
you also have to know
how you should fight
my answer is
play by your own rules
but how do you do that
it is as simple as it sounds
you must play to win
you cannot expect victory and plan for
defeat
you have to believe
that you are better
than your left liberal opponents are
and don't care what the liberals say
they always say you will lose they say
it cannot be done
you just have to prove them wrong
but there is one thing i have learned
we cannot fight successfully by liberal
means
because our opponents use liberal
institutions concept and language to
disguise their marxist and hegemony's
plans
politics
my friend are not enough right this war
is a cultural war
we have to revitalize
we have to revitalize our churches our
families our universities and our
community institutions
hungary
christianity will be the solution to all
of these problems
hungary many of which don't exist
proud but
david-sized nation
standing alone against the vote
globalist goliath
we invite the solitarity of the american
conservatives
they are in total attack
so we need a total defense
you have to be brave
if you feel fear
you have a job to do
the only thing
the hungarians can show you is
how to fight back
by our own rules
let me give you a couple of examples oh
no he's got a rap he's completely lost
the crowd and this is a very dangerous
speech by the way ladies and gentlemen
we were the first ones in europe
who said no to illegal migration
and stopped the invasion of illegal
migrants
you guys recognizing this rhetoric from
anywhere
we believe
that stopping illegal migration
is necessary to protect our nation
if the crowd's back that's for sure i
did to ask the people
whether they want illegal migration or
not
we had a referendum
hungarian people decided
they don't want migration so
they don't want to play by the rules of
the progressives
they rejected the false claim
that migrants cannot be stopped and
forced us leaders to act
and we stopped illegal migration we have
actually built that wall and it stopped
illegal migration
as tucker carson said
when he visited us
quote
it's not a high-tech wall
but guarded by people
who love their country
and the border protection system works
during
the great migration crisis in 2015
four hundred thousand illegal migrants
came to our borders
this is almost three times as much as
genghis khan had when he invaded europe
after
we built relevant comparison to reduce
illegal migration to zero
this year
this year
we have already suffered
160 000
illegal border crossing attempts
160 000 illegal border crossing attempts
so
we had the hungarian borders catch every
illegal migrant
and escort them back
to the other side this sounds sort of
like when the ahmadinejad said iran has
no gay people does something about this
is seeming weird the rule is simple
you can apply for a zealous
at our embassies
but if you try to come to hungary
illegally you will never ever make it
even though
even though we are under pressure not
only from the south
but also from the eckhart of the
european union as well
yes this is the case my friend
they want us to give up our zero
migration policy
because they also know
that this is the decisive and final
battle of the future
but the future is
the most important thing
we can give to our children and our
grandchildren so in hungary we will
never surrender
dear friends
let's move on family policy
which is the heart of our politics oh my
god
is he supposed to be speaking this long
that families should not be protected
in europe they say
there is no such thing as family
because love is love and family is
family
if you cannot define family
nothing is a family
and they say
oh is this the homophobic part of the
speech is that the oppression of the
so-called patriarchy begins
but in case of family policy in hungary
we again played by our own rules
we know that family is the place
to transfer the values of parents to the
next generation
if traditional families are gone
there is nothing that can save the west
from going under ah
therefore
last year in hungary so so far it's the
policy what he's laying out is no
immigrants
christian country
no
bad people like george soros
and only traditional families
quite quite a country he's painting a
picture of here the state takes over
your student loans
after your third child
women are exempt from paying personal
income tax for life
after the birth of their fourth child
and we are fighting to extend the same
zero tax policy for mothers with three
children
so
if you are not married yet you should
immediately find the hungarian wife
there you go
in the
in the last 10 years ladies and
gentlemen the last 10 years
the number of marriages has doubled
and the number of abortions has halved
in hungary it's not a bad start
and we will ban men
dear friends
in hungary
we had to build not just a physical of
all on our borders
and the financial around our families
but the legal wall around our children
to protect them from the gender ideology
that targets them here it goes
will he do the routine where he pretends
to lift weights like trump
should follow
the progressive way of parenting if they
refuse to do so
they should be forced by the state
the hungarians know this old communist
trick and we reject it
hungarian people rejected sexual
orientation programs in schools without
parental consent at the referendum again
sounds like trump never before has there
been a referendum
in the long history of hungary
where such a huge majority of people
said no to gender
or anything
now the hungarian they said no to gender
or anything constitution protects
families and children
let me quote a few sentences from our
hungarian fundamental law oh no
our constitution reads
the family
and the nation constitute
the principal framework of our
coexistence
hungarian state institutions are obliged
to protect the christian culture of
hungary
hungary shall protect the institution of
marriage
as the union of
one man and one woman
it's not sounding to me like hungary is
a place i would ever be interested in
living the way it's going right now
family ties shall be based on marriage
all the relationship between parents and
children
to sum up
the mother is a woman
the father is a man and leave our kids
alone full stop end of discussion wow
the blatantly homophobic transphobic
moments generating a standing ovation at
cpac these people are sick
these people are disgusting look at this
they they have not been this fired up
until it became overtly homophobic and
transphobic
dear friends
another factor of our success is
that my government is devoted to law and
order
without compromise right
we decided
we decided we don't need more genders we
need more rangers
we need more what rangers did he
notice
we believe
we believe there is no freedom without
order
if there is no order you get chaos
in hungary
law enforcement agencies are not
people's enemies
they are the guardians of freedom
therefore law should not protect
criminals
but protect the victims and those who
are defending the law police should be
well respected
so
i mean this could be translated even
translate it's in english what i mean is
the examples could be adjusted to be
about the us rather than hungary and it
would be a trump speech verbatim few
european capitals
where you can walk around safely even in
night time wow even at night in hungary
you will only hear
more funds to the police that's crazy
and finally a few remarks on taxation
it's very rare that in a country you can
walk around at night that's not common
always want your money
they love higher taxes
we believe that people should have their
money in their own hands
to this end
we introduced a flat tax on personal
income which is currently 15 percent
what's funny is there's a lot of people
in the audience who don't realize that
based on their income their effective
tax rate might already be 15 or lower
they have no idea which was the biggest
tax cut in europe
we have the lowest corporate income tax
in europe which is flat
nine percent
with this low corporate income tax last
year
we had a 27 percent investment rate
which was among the best in europe
just recently
we came under fire again
when we went against the global minimum
tax initiative by the way if all these
initiatives are so great for their
economy why is their economy not doing
so well murray is the last man standing
but the empire always strikes back
the current u.s administration
decided to terminate
the tax treaty between hungary and the
united states
which was probably the best tax deal
ever negotiated
it was good for us investors
there are 1
700 u.s companies operating in hungary
i think it was indeed the revenge of the
left
because the u.s treasury
somehow forgot
that they have a very similar treaty
with russia
but not with hungary anymore funny isn't
it
ladies and gentlemen finally we need to
talk about the war
the war
ukraine is our neighbor
we are in
full solidarity with them
do you attack
mild clapping hence ukraine
has forced close to 1 million refugees
to hungary so far
currently
more than 10 000 refugees every day
the majority of these refugees ventures
further into europe
but one million people entering a
country of 10 million is a lot
in my view
didn't he just say they have 15 million
people like earlier in the speech he
said the population was 15 million now
he says they just lost 5 million people
during the speech of peace
without american russian talks there
will never be peace in ukraine
more and more people will die and suffer
and our economies will come to the brink
of collapse
i cannot tell you what to do
it's your sovereign decision
i can however tell you one thing
only strong leaders are able to make
peace
we
we in the neighborhood of ukraine
this speech is so bad five million
people left hungary strong leaders
who are capable of negotiating a peace
deal
may they may they please help us we need
a strong america with a strong leader
dear friends
dear friends i think i have provoked you
long enough
yeah please
so before matchlap takes my microphone
away
let's come to a conclusion
the word has several great nations
but none with the power and influence of
the united states
for better or for worse
the word looks to you for the future
and the future of the west is in grave
doubt
we in the west have not faced the crisis
like this for a long time
the ideological wars of the 20th century
against the totalitarian powers
of nazi germany and soviet union were
terrible
but democratic west rallied
and defeated them both
now the west is at war with itself
we have seen
what kind of future the globalist ruling
class has to offer
but we have a different future in mind
the globalist can all go to hell i have
come to texas
obama
please proceed
and we will ban men
very very low information crowd huh
no offense to hungary but imagine being
in the u.s and you're like wow our big
ally is this nut from hungary the reveal
never be found by taking the path of
least resistance
we must take back the institutions in
washington and in brussels
we must find friends and allies in one
another
we must coordinate the movement of our
troops
because we face the same challenge
you have midterm elections this year
then presidential
and congressional elections in 24
and we will have election in the
european parliament same year
these two locations will define the two
fronts in the battle
being fought for western civilization
today we hold neither of them
yet we need both
you have two years to get ready
i have to tell
it won't be easy
but
don't be afraid just believe in saint
john paul's the polish pope's teaching
there is no enemy
that christ has not already defeated so
let's go out and do it god bless texas
god bless our friendship
good luck and goodbye
[Music]
wow
look at this guy oh what a strange walk
[Music]
dear god
[Music]
all right anyway uh that was genuinely
horrifying i mean genuine genuinely
people in the audience saying it was
unsettling that it was dangerous that it
was scary
um
yeah he has that dictatorial ambition
we're gonna skip this this i believe
based on the agenda is attorney general
of texas jeff landry i really could not
care less what this guy has to say he's
absolutely horrifying we're gonna keep
an eye on things because coming up very
soon papa john the anti-health insurance
pizza guy will be speaking
dan patrick the lieutenant governor of
texas will be speaking
and then fox news propaganda sean
hannity will be speaking that's all
coming up here so please stand by
a lot going on today a lot a lot a lot
and we i have so many things i want to
go over with you as well
uh but what an absolutely fascist
dystopia
uh outlined there by the hungarian
president victor orban horrible horrible
horrible stuff
uh mark fillion via super chat saying do
you still need people giving free
memberships yeah listen we have 300
people who have requested free
memberships right now
if you want a free membership
new and improved as of this week go to
davidpakman.com free membership just
fill in your name and email and we'll
we'll get you a free membership as they
come in
now if you can give a free membership
this would be an absolutely perfect time
to do it go to our website
joinpakman.com
check the box this is a gift if you want
to give away a membership and we do have
a coupon code obama
and when you type that in
the prices become absolutely criminal
almost as criminal as what alex jones
seems to be wrapped up in so it sounds
like communism because it is it is
indeed memberships and i will thank
everybody oh and three people just
signed up
juan
troll man juan has gifted a membership
kevin guldi has gifted a membership and
martin fillion is gifted a membership
that puts us at 40. i also want to make
sure everyone on twitch gets a thank you
that includes j cruz conqueso
jen here for the gift and sub
good guy jj and charles weyland
that puts us at 46 today very much
appreciate that
ian says this is despicable ear and hate
speech
in ataroa new zealand we were successful
with sars kov2
this mined virus has a long incubation
and is transmitted without any contact
it is spreading here oh you guys have
trumpism in new zealand is that what
you're saying
that doesn't sound particularly good
thanks to linda acevedo for the
subscription at joinedpakman.com you're
number 47 today uh let's do some unban
requests this is extraordinarily risky
when you um
when you get banned on twitch
you were able
to request an unban
okay
so let's see if we can do this here
uh how do i do this there we go
um okay
so a user who goes by the name fart
brazil showed up and put keck w about a
hundred times
and then said imagine voting for
demented joe over this patriot
uh i don't i don't love this let's see
if we can get the there we go
um that's just a perma-ban and i don't
even care okay that's just it's a
perma-ban
next user ijoy showed up and said only
you are a [ __ ]
and that's a perma-ban very very easy
one these are easy
next user sahira
eucentrist liberals are awful what else
did they say
liberals telling me to move to a
different country
instigating a lot of stuff
and this is an unban it seemed they just
needed to cool off i'm okay unbanning
that here's a user who showed up and
just did um
looks like
penis art uh that's just a perma band
that's too stupid
man
gay and then okay yeah this is a
perma-ban
these are just too easy guys i can
adjudicate these
they signed up and said david cuckman
and then their unban request was
president gay biden
that's a perma-ban
um let's see trump would have our
borders secure gas would be cheap trump
24
as long as they're crazy libtards you
ain't going to stop him from murdering
demon rats are the number one enemy of
america
extend you are a fool trump had
everything going strong they were banned
their unbanned request is free speech
girls that's a deny just i don't need
you here
these are so easy
here's another user
oggs naboni
who said fake made up story barack iran
bent you over for eight years
empty platitudes no substance
geesh this guy is a fraud they were
banned fake outrage for trump naming the
victims effing slimeball streaming at
for-profit that's a perma-ban
love trump24 love trump he's great the
democrats are in the process of wrecking
the usa they were banned
and then their unbanned request is why
am i banned have you taken a look at
what the democrats have done to the usa
since my comment
i think that's a perma-ban just it's
hard to imagine they're going to come
back
penguin pusher showed up and said david
pakman more like f my ass man
their unban request is my bad it was
just a meme
that was out of line i promise not to
say crazy inappropriate stuff like that
all right i'll give him the benefit of
the doubt that's an unban
build that wall and let mexico have
sleepy joe build that wall build that
wall
they were banned then they said sorry
guess it was the weekend for me i was
probably drunk i'm not usually [ __ ]
like that that's just a perma-ban based
if you're gonna try to get yourself
unbanned by saying [ __ ] it's a perma
guys i mean this this is just crazy
here's another user hesh rat
they said to someone show me your
titties in the chat that's a no i mean
it's just a no
i made a joke in poor taste and meant it
as a joke not literally
i could go either way on this one i mean
they're saying it was a joke what do you
guys think
it's completely inappropriate but
they're saying it was a joke
unbanned unban
unban give them another chance all right
we can go they get a chance
um how many more oh just two more god
i'm getting sick of this
minister of truth they scared of free
speech the people 2024 100 minutes is
still almost 100 more minutes than biden
can do hi i'm confused i don't know
which comment got me banned
apologize yeah this is an unb i can very
easily see that's an unban
and then lastly
uh thoughts on hunter biden's laptop
biden only had 90 of msm stations
colluding to carry his decrepit tush
across the finish line
they were banned sorry that you're too
much of a coward to deal with opposing
thoughts you boring fraud
that's a deny this would be an unban if
their unbanned request was polite
but because the unbanned request was so
rude it's a perma
all right guys so we've done that i'm
glad to have taken care of that business
as we wait here for the next speakers i
want to say thank you to breezy aj
scorpio and slip and shank for the
twitch prime subscriptions folks that
puts us at 50. over on the website andy
king is a new member number 51
and david levin has gifted a
subscription that's number 52.
very very much appreciate that
and then now
via super chat
david i try to catch you live when i can
but can't always do so i listen to your
program every night and you're my
favorite centrist oh my god no guys i
hope that that's a joke as we all know
i've taken my political compass tests
endless times
and uh
it's very very left very left all right
let's look at a couple of other things i
don't know how many of you saw this but
glenn greenwald one of the last true
leftists glenn greenwald
sort of whitewashed alex jones's
handling of sandy hook take a listen to
this
so you know i mentioned before i i want
to ask you a little bit about sandy hook
i know the expectation is i'm supposed
to come here and bash you over the head
about go ahead i'm sorry i know i have
no interest in doing that i don't give a
[ __ ] what the expectations are it would
bore me if i tried you've talked about
it extensively for people who are
interested in it you've been deposed
about it you've talked for hours about
it people interested in the particulars
can go watch that if they want i'm not
going to jump through hoops in order to
like appease people anger that i'm here
i do go want to ask you about a question
that i'm actually interested in myself
which is
you know you
have just you just said that that you
have made mistakes obviously one of
those is the stuff you said about sandy
hook we watched you in the film come
very clean about the fact that you made
statements that turned out to be untrue
you've obviously spent a lot of kind of
reflective time it's like the soulful
alex jones we got to see in the last
part he's really reflected on his
mistakes
the film
what is it that you think
caused you to do that um i mean you
referenced some things i you know and i
just i identify with it myself that when
you know people who lie for a living
are telling you that you're a liar when
people who are whose job it is to spread
this information are accusing you of
doing that you kind of want to dig in a
little bit and and not give an inch to
people who
you know aren't criticizing you in good
faith but what is it about kind of how
social media works about how kind of
yeah alex tell us like how social media
victimized you and all of that stuff
groups function have you thought about
some of the psychological and cultural
dynamics that that led you to to make
some of those mistakes
alex please tell us how all of the
horrible things you said about sandy
hook including that the deaths of
children were imagined
uh tell us how that was actually a
result of how social media treated you
dear god that is glenn greenwald off the
rails completely off the rails here is
papa john who will soon be speaking
let's listen to what he has to say he's
the pizza man
who opposed obamacare because it was
going to have to it was going to cost
him like 10 cents a pizza to give every
employee health care so he was against
it
john schneider so thank you so much for
joining us today thanks liz for having
me thank you so you are speaking around
3 p.m today what is the topic of
conversation going to be today for you
yeah well what we're going to talk about
is the
comparisons analogically between the
1970s and the 2020s we've seen this
movie before what's the saying that if
you don't learn from history repeat the
same mistakes absolutely we had you know
what
interest rates double triple gas prices
were
exorbitant if you could even get to the
pump we had weak leadership on ford this
is who's speaking about economics at
cpac
my dad started uh five or six businesses
he was a zero entrepreneur that's where
you get it from you got it from
genetically yeah and all six of them
were bankrupted
and so
that's such a good businessman i guess
he's like what a great businessman he's
like all his businesses went bankrupt oh
wow
and really anti-entrepreneurship
settlement you have to walk them out on
their shoes and i watched my dad i
watched the family i don't know if
you've ever been bankrupt and have
trouble paying your bills but after five
or six fold she's bankrupted a dozen
companies
ronald reagan comes in
reaganomics and then 1984 i started papa
john's
and
you know sixteen hundred dollars in a
broom closet and back to the bar and
then we did four billion dollars last
year i was there
we i couldn't have done that without
when he says last year i was there he
was like pushed out right for some of
the insane things he said wasn't he
pushed out of the of running papa john's
i think all right so we're going to hear
from him very soon marianne zimmerman
says dear david please tell your
audience that orban in no way represents
the eu or bon is a parasite in europe
and there are serious talks on how to
kick hungary out of the eu love from
copenhagen denmark thank you mary anne
for the update that's relevant context i
would say
hit the like button this man deserves it
absolutely emily thank you please like
the stream if you were watching on
youtube
we have a humiliating 800 likes in a
completely arbitrary and meaningless
metric and it's making us look bad
david please rank the contemporary
threats are reported by mr jones dracula
wolfman frankenstein mummy and bigfoot
i would say that the biggest threat is
wolfman
followed by bigfoot
dracula
mummy
and then frankenstein last that's how i
would rank those threats
can we start a petition to rename papa
john's to pizza shack s-h-a-q
i mean do whatever you want
you're not going to find me having any
papa john's pizza that's for damn sure i
go with local pizzerias local local
local local
thank you to elevated disc golf for the
twitch prime subscription your number 53
today folks if we get to 100 today we
lock in another at least one more stream
tomorrow
either or the prompt rally
or and or cpac day two
the two ways to trigger this are number
one sign up on my website joinpakman.com
memberships are our primary source of
funding you can use the coupon code
indict
to get a discount i would love for you
to do that if you're watching on twitch
you can also sign up via twitch or
twitch prime twitch or twitch prime
and um that'll also count which is a
beautiful thing
okay
let's get to a few other things here
uh here is
matt gates this is a really strange
thing matt gates said matt gates says
migrants are creating food shortages
by destroying monarch butterfly habitats
i have never heard this before
our america is not for the illegal
aliens who leave our nation poorer
dirtier and less safe
they have made a mockery of our laws
and illegal aliens have destroyed
some of the most critical monarch
butterfly habitat in the world
now he cares about that these are the
people where when you go hey oil usage
is killing a thousand species a year
they go what you care about some
salamander man you care about some frog
and then now all of a sudden he's like
butterflies are getting killed
i bet you didn't know that and before
you say the monarch butterfly is not all
that significant we need the monarch
butterfly to pollinate our fields for
the food that we eat here in our country
what about bees
this is wild how can anyone take these
people seriously i mean truly it is it
is bizarre
bizarre
a friend for ian says a friend from via
super chat a friend from university is a
trumpist we met for beers and he told me
this
luckily i'd watched your show that day
and schooled him on tariffs excellent
i may have missed it but david do you
know if ivana trump was cremated because
if she was then what is buried on the
golf course i have no idea emily i i
quite frankly i did not follow that
uh this is sick monarch butterflies are
symbols of hope for immigrants
particularly mexican i i
have no idea if that's a joke i
genuinely have no clue whether that's a
joke
thanks to shorty for the twitch prime
subscription you're number 54 today we
are standing by for the resumption of
cpac i did want to see if we had any
other streams it's always good to have a
backup stream
cpac live
uh
let's see what we've got here live
uh there really aren't that many streams
today huh
see if we've got more
there's like a very low quality stream
that i found
let's see if on the cpac website itself
there's anything while we listen to papa
john arithmetics an opinion i mean i ask
him are you angry because you're stupid
are you stupid because you're angry
the answer is flatter they're stupid
because they're angry they're so full of
hate and guilt and shame all right
here's another stream of this stuff
let's see what we've got here
is this live it appears to be certainly
a lot of that crime has to do with
defunding the the police and and
democrat judges and democrat districts
of attorney that simply won't prosecute
and let people out uh to you know with
with personal recognizance no bail in
looking at the agenda
it seems that this is
thousands tens of thousands of the elite
biden has cue cards we have a solution
it's called
and then after this papa john will be
speaking in the united states has served
time and then been deported and now
they're coming back in there are
thousands of those type of people and
the american people are paying through
the nose in blood and toil and so we're
going to mute that for now and we've got
to educate all what the heck we've got
to medicate that's right and i i got to
say sarah you've i mean you first of all
you left back i mean state of virginia
she was living up near me she was
literally my neighbor and all of a
sudden i get a call from her she's like
i'm moving to texas i'm like what
okay
we're just gonna silence that for the
time being and then we're going to get
back to that um we're going to get back
to that momentarily very very strange
stuff going on all right i know a lot of
you are anxious to see some new clips
from the alex jones trial here's uh okay
here was a reference to intimate
messages between alex jones and roger
stone it's kind of interesting is all of
the stuff in there he cannot now come
into court and claim 2.3 gigabytes of
phone material blanket designation of
confidentiality the protective order
prohibits it you must identify
specifically the documents value and and
things like like mr jones and his
intimate messages with roger stone are
not confidential they are not trends
intimate messages that would be very
interesting to learn more about
uh let's see what else we have here
uh okay so clips from the orban disaster
that we watched
uh let's see if we have any more alex
jones stuff
maggo world celebrates we know about
that
a lot of cpac stuff
where are the new alex jones clips i'm
sure that i have them
oh yeah this was kind of a funny moment
this is in today's podcast what
compensation would you believe to be
appropriate
what compensation do i think appropriate
despite these numbers that were
presented the best week we ever had
that's when it was starting
and
there was a run on historical food
nationwide
uh and so they
mr jones
i'm just saying we don't
[Music]
it doesn't really matter
about that
i understand but i can answer the
question however i wish i'm not borrowed
from talking about where we're at
financially no you are at this stage
right now the question is what
compensation would be appropriate
any compensation above
two million dollars will
sink us and
we'll be shut down no appropriate not to
you appropriate for what happened to
them i mean i mean i think it's
appropriate for whatever whatever you
decide you want to
because i'm not really
that's a great answer thank you that is
the exact answer the judge was looking
for guys uh more than a two million
dollar settlement award rather
will sink infowars
pretty based i've got to tell you very
very interesting
um
alex jones is now promoting
instahard
huh
interesting
what else do we have here
this was earlier
all right of marjorie taylor green uh
what's she up to they call this common
phrases and references
and they consider um they said that the
danger militia violent extremists
talk about certain individuals to be
martyrs and one of the names they just
recently added is ashley babbitt who was
an unarmed woman who was shot and killed
during inside the capitol on january 6
who by the way
is on video hitting someone in the face
that was breaking the glass to go into
the speaker's lobby ashley babbitt was
someone that was trying to stop them
from going in and that's on video and
there's proof of it but yet now her name
is on this fbi militia violent extremism
list
this is completely wrong this is
absolutely wrong ashley babbitt was a
veteran
she was not someone that was interested
in in attacking the united states
government she was trying to stop them
just because she was walking around in
there that's not what an entire
investigation found actually like the
entire investigation did not find that
that's what took place
uh but i guess we're supposed to believe
marjorie taylor green knows more
chandler says speaking of gas prices as
john was mentioning i noticed that gas
prices here in texas are going back to
normal the lowest price in my town is
359. yeah let's check take a look at the
latest um
chart as far as
gas prices go
they're really coming down very quickly
uh gas prices
basically started declining around
mid-june
and they continue down soon national gas
prices might even go below four bucks a
gallon they were over five that's that's
you know that will be more than a 20
reduction it's it's quite notable i'm
not even praising joe biden for it as
you guys all know
i don't play these games with gas prices
i mean i'll jokingly play them but i'm
not actually being serious about it
presidents have very very very little to
do with gas prices and uh
it
yeah
big dumps prices are dumping that's
absolutely for sure
uh let's see what else i had here oh we
were looking at a couple of other things
here let's see what else we've got
um
biden
where is oh this was weird ted cruz put
a boot up on the counter
during a speech during a hearing today
violent extremist militia well i will
self-report right now
that every day in the senate i wear my
boots
that have the gonzales battle flag on
the back of them right
very very important declaration that ted
cruz made there uh showing us his boots
um and let's see what else we have here
the alex jones stuff we've been talking
about
here's marjorie taylor green she's
against the inflation reduction act
and i think it should be called the
bring back blackouts bill because that's
what it's all about no the blackouts are
in texas
it's going to plunge us back in time
uh you know before the luxuries of
things like air conditioning and heat
and refrigeration
maybe hot showers in the wintertime
so she has no idea what she's talking
about that's for damn sure
uh
let's see what else we have here
after alex jones lawyers claim plaintiff
lawyers violated their attorney client
privilege with his text messages he
informs the court they had previously
inadvertently disclosed other privileged
info that the court isn't even aware of
oh this i have to hear
what's interesting to me is this is not
the first time
that materials like this have been
inadvertently produced in this case as
you may remember from prior hearings mr
barnes inadvertently produced materials
now in that case some of that
information ended up coming out they
ended up letting me keep some of it and
we ended up about it but there were
attorney community county community
excuse me attorney-client communications
in there which you don't know about
which i do which they did follow 193.3
and they did identify those by eights
page numbers said here is the privilege
and when that happened i promptly
returned them and destroyed all my
copies
mr reynold is right now
using a fig leaf of this motion to say i
violated things to put a fig over his
own malpractice over
man the trial has become such a joke
it's it's truly stunning truly truly
stunning all right it looks like this is
fortunately ending let's see poor kamala
harris they're like y'all stay away from
us because they're so unpopular they
don't even want them on the downtown
trail and i've been endorsed by
president trump he called me and gave me
his endorsement so i appreciate that
very much
but he was right about being woke you
you brought it up mercedes you were
saying you know
what is your pronoun i mean i think
that's what we're seeing now right we're
seeing this kind of radical leftist
movement in our schools we are and on
television
and at the hearings and we hear it
creeping through our society and then if
you disagree with the radical left they
try to ostracize you they relegate you
to censorship um and their friends in
the media like twitter and facebook and
you know these big social media giants
that we all use because it all became a
part of our life right a global we're
globally connected and we rely on that
and then all of a sudden we realize well
wait a minute
we're living really in 1984 right in a
future where you know it's literally
1984. we have to know what's going on
and um all of these pieces need to fit i
mean we can't just say because
president biden's been the worst
president we've ever seen i mean he made
jimmy carter smile we were talking about
that you know um but the worst president
that we're going to just win this that
november is going to come and we don't
need to do anything or that 2024 is
going to get here and we're going to
have a new man in office that may not
necessarily be the case let's hope we
can't underestimate
what the democrats are willing and going
to try to do and the political machine
behind them and i think that's what
makes cpac so miraculous and important
it's a miracle here is a place where we
can get together
talk out our issues work together as a
team and fight to win our country back
and that is absolutely what we have to
do
[Applause]
congressman let me ask you
when it comes to election integrity this
seems to be an issue that keeps popping
up and i know we travel across the
country and it's very basic things like
ensuring we have a voter id in place and
then you have the gems people are
horrible hey by the way this i haven't
looked into this can anybody explain to
me what dark brandon is somebody in the
chat just mentioned it and i saw that
this morning trending
what the hell is dark brandon i don't
know is it pro-biden or anti-biden i
don't even understand what it is
by the way thanks to scrpzr
for the twitch prime subscription your
number 55 today dark brandon is
pro-biden
it's an ironic pro-biden meme okay
that's interesting
dark brandon dear god
um
it's interesting though nonetheless
nonetheless let's do a couple voicemails
as we wait for the next speaker papa
john
here is a voicemail from juan
hey david it's juan here
so i'm watching you live and uh the guy
says that communists and progressives
are the same
well i'm taking your advice and i'm
trying to
dissect
and perhaps
debunk what he said
and i hope you could uh see if i get
some perks and improvement here
i think he's wrong based on a quick
google search
yeah listen no communists and
progressives are not the same thing
progressivism is one thing communism is
another thing social you don't even need
to google that juan your instinct was
correct though your instinct was correct
hey this is one of our viewers who's
black and his name is brandon he says he
is dark brandon i guess in a sense
that's technically true very nicely done
brandon i like that
uh
a lot of people getting very very fired
up about
dark brandon
oh man
that is something else
let's see what else we have as far as
voicemails go
hey david it's aidan from canada so a
few parts of this alex jones trial that
i mean
i gotta give you credit for
this because you've called this many
times
um one time in the alex jones trial
he's
asked about kind of why he would believe
these things and like you've presumed or
explained many times he says
well it's just kind of hard it's easier
to believe there's a conspiracy than to
believe someone would shoot up a
a school it's
he said it's just hard to believe that
another time um
his
assistant was being
uh was being uh
was testifying and he and she said
uh that
it's easier for
their audience to believe
these things than to believe than to
believe that someone could shoot up a
school and this is just what you've been
seeing for
a long time so
okay
uh let's see what else we have here
hey david
i'm wondering how is our friend's
pillow going to be
using his coffee
um well he's suing all machines so that
would presumably include keurig
it would include
espresso makers
so
maybe even potentially uh depending on
the course maybe even french presses
um so how do you think he's going to be
using the coffee
i'd love to hear your uh your thoughts i
assume coffee enemas is what pillow is
going to be doing that's the only thing
i can think of david i do a man james
from virginia
i am dying right now watching your uh
your show and just watching your face
during the uh
utter collapse of alex jones confidence
while being confronted with a brilliant
display by the plaintiff oh my god your
face says it all brother it is great
anyway it's a wonderful uh
to see him finally be confronted with
truth instead of
you know what he does for a living yeah
it turns out anyway i love your show
brother during when when the rules are
the rules of a court of law
the things alex jones says very quickly
implode and don't don't make any sense
at all as if they made sense anyway
uh let's see what other voicemails we
have here as we stand by for the next
element
um
what else do we have
a lot of strange voicemails here i will
say
hey david and jeff from colorado i just
had a question regarding the uh text
messages that
have been scrubbed from
uh dod phones secret service etc
isn't there a
like a
cloud backup that's automatically
you would think performed on these
iphones
or do they block
those
procedures from happening as well
thanks a lot let me show bye
it's all part of what's weird there's no
way that that is not a question that
should be asked
uh let's see what we have going on here
and listen a bit
and you had also the the the right they
wouldn't let us even talk about hunter
biden they didn't even investigate into
that right we couldn't even utter the
words hunter but not because
yeah so when the when the fbi is telling
you
and telling me
you know oh you got to stop that you
know that don't go any further down that
road and then we find out christopher
steele's dossier was a bunch of lies
that they were perpetrating lies that
were based on
democratic talking points that were
perpetuated by hillary clinton and her
lawyers and the dnc and it became a huge
problem america was embroiled in for
over five years and then we see the
truth which of course is hunter biden
and his laptop
and then they use it and turn against us
and say no that's not true the real
story here is hunter biden's laptop the
national security task force the
republican conference
and i can tell you one thing you're
going to start seeing when we get the
majority back in january and that is a
lot of there's evidence that uh hunter
was able to beat minesweeper on the
hardest level
and that suggests that he was cheating
and it needs to be investigated topics
and uh we can't we can't choose the
topic we can't choose a witness for the
most part uh we can't
get a bill to the floor right uh we're
pretty much just
basically having a message that's all we
have but i can tell you the oversight
committees and every single committee
that we have
in the house of representatives will be
doing
oversight hearings of our own and we
will be looking in and we will bring
people forward the fbi doesn't want to
do their job apparently we've seen that
so we're going to do it for them of
course we have to it's interesting how
these people live in a complete
alternate reality where
they say the fbi is doing things that
aren't happening
they believe the hunter biden laptop is
the real story they continue to talk
about hillary's emails they continue to
insist that the 2020 election was stolen
it's a it's a complete and total fantasy
world where it's not that they have
different facts they just have no facts
facts don't matter mercedes 30 seconds
to each of you
uh as we've delved into joe biden's i
think big big problems that he has and
we only got through half of them uh what
are your thoughts moving forward
and and your final thoughts on this my
final thoughts are this i mean it's
going to be and i you know i say this
every time on my podcast
it's up to the american people we're in
charge and we have to remember that it's
not about washington d.c we're the boss
we hire them
of course congressmen and with all due
respect we hire them to do the work for
us as constituents
and until we got to get up off the couch
we got to get involved we've got to get
politically active to ensure that they
are doing that job and when they don't
we got to vote them out and say goodbye
and that is going to make a difference
2024 cannot come fast enough and by god
midterms cannot come fast enough but
that requires all of us to do our to do
our part and to do our role as americans
is to get out there and vote and i
believe in that wholeheartedly
thank you
congressman
i didn't think i would ever see the
united states of america in this state
that we are seeing today
i've served in the u.s air force i've
served in the u.s army
my son was a navy seal
my dad was a u.s army trooper in this in
the pacific during world war ii
and the debacle we saw in afghanistan
the withdrawal and the the ramifications
repercussions of that i don't think you
would have seen a ukrainian invasion by
russia had we had president trump in
there believe you me but we have got to
have new
leadership
the america you know i think it was
alexander the great said
it's not an army of lions led by a sheep
that i fear
it's an army of sheep led by a lion wow
we've got to get some lions in the
leadership positions of this country
we've got to get some honest government
and it's up we're we're
a nation by of and for the people
the people have got to go to the polls
and they're the ones that have to make
this choice i have people come up and
say congressman why do you allow this to
happen how how come you can't stop this
how come you're doing this or not doing
that and i say elections have
consequences and by gosh they have
consequences and we're living them right
today and every time you go fill your
car up every time you go
buy groceries
whenever you see uh someone having their
rights taken away from them a weaponized
doj or fbi the the corruption that is
going on in this in this nation is
unbelievable but it can be fixed and it
can be fixed at the ballot box folks so
we have to do our job and we have to get
a lion to lead this country it's quite
pedantic all of it really all right i
don't have a choice well lioness and
lyon here on stage let's give a round of
applause for sarah carter and
congressman babin thank you so much
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right we've got two more sensational
congressmen coming up here
to talk about the solutions and i'm
gonna introduce them let's give a round
of applause congressman byron donalds
from the great state of florida
and congressman roger williams from the
great state of texas
all right papa john comes up after these
guys i'm gonna take a five and then
we'll be back for papa john but the
stream continues
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay i think the women in the front
almost fainted when they saw byron cpac
yeah right do you see her hand motions
over here it was it was fabulous did you
guys see this over here yeah what was it
what was it
everybody at the same time ready one two
three
that's going to be our new cpac like
secret handshake you know
yeah exactly there we go
okay guys gentlemen it's wonderful to
see you i you were with your wife doing
the cpac activism boot camp training how
fabulous was that
it was just like this yeah
activism training was fantastic
there's so many people right here in
dallas texas the conservative movement
is alive and well
passionate about everything from
education to border security and making
sure we get back on track my wife is
right over there my wife here's erica he
goes wave over there stand up erica
stand up go ahead
but it was a great event and i think the
biggest thing is
people
for of course they're tired
but they want to do something about it
and i think that the conservative
movement is prepared to do something
about it and not just in 2022 but in
every year to come the time has come
from this first step up take on this
battle take the country back save
america again
we got to save it again
but we're going to do that work starting
this november congressman roger williams
i'm we're first i'm a fan of both of you
we were just talking with sarah and with
one of your colleagues congressman babin
we were talking about all the bad
problems i mean it was
dark it was sad we were we didn't even
get through half the problems it was
like a list
but here you are we're the happy
warriors we got to find solutions to
these problems
so this is going to be a very tough task
but let's go and break this down so
congressman williams i'll start with you
how do
we solve these very complex problems
where the democrats
they can't even define what a woman is
is they can't even define what recession
is and they think men can get pregnant
break it down for me
that scares me to death
but listen you know this is an important
time every year we've always said have
we that it's the most important election
of our life yes have we said that so
many right i believe this is the most
important lecture of our lifetime and
we've got to have answers we don't want
to just have rhetoric we got to make
sure we don't over promise uh i've i've
said all along we need to pick three or
four things we can do and make it happen
as we go into 2024 but this is serious
stuff that we're involved in just all
the things mercedes that you said who
would have thought we'd ever be
negotiating this or even talking about
it but we're on the right track we are
the party of lower taxes less government
try to cut spending defend borders uh
these this is what we stand for and uh
we're gonna have to start uh uh
making people understand where our pro
what we stand for and we'll have to be
able to say it i was in the airport the
other day
and when i got off the airplane people
knew that i was on the airplane about 15
of them and they began to yell and
scream at me with signs and try to
follow me up the elevator and in the
past
bar and i've kind of let it go right
because we're we're peaceful people we
we got things to get done but i had all
i can take and i dropped my briefcase i
remember thinking myself i hope somebody
is taping this
because i tore this woman was yelling at
me about this and that her body and this
and that
and i finally i finally
fired back at her i didn't say anything
bad but i fired back at her with the
truth right the truce on our side we're
on the right side and all of a sudden
she broke down and just started crying
and she said i've never been talked to
by a man like that in my life
well i was talking about america and the
great things that we have and her
husband took her away and i tell you
that story only because
in the past we may not have been
fighters we have been thinkers
but the other side cannot take a punch
they showed me that the other day they
don't have truth on their side they
don't have facts on their side all they
do is lie
and we have to fire back at them
and we have to run through the finish
line and people need to know that the
best government is the less government
and all the things we believe in
conservative values but we're on the
right side we have to sell it we have to
punch them back because they can't take
a punch that's what i would say that's
our charge as we go into this next uh
several months is to remember who we are
what we are and we've got to make things
like tax cuts permanent that has to
happen we're coming out of the greatest
economy we ever saw we saw it torn up in
18 months i'm a small business owner i
employ hundreds of people right next
door in fort worth texas
and i'm old enough i remember in 1981
and high inflation and high interest
rates but we've seen the greatest
economy come down out to once very
average we have to build it back we can
and i think we will we got the greatest
workforce there is in the world if we
let them work right
absolutely and we've got uh and small
business and and and letting we got a
great we can have startups again main
street still employs 75 of the workforce
75 5 of the payroll is in small
businesses they're being attacked by
this guy and joe manchin for crying out
loud and to help small business he's
saying in main street well we're going
to raise your taxes we're going to hire
67 or 87 000 irs agents and oh by the
way don't deduct that interest but we're
helping small business
this is the kind of stuff they lie all
the time we got to fix it we will fix it
by getting the house back in november
and then moving forward and getting the
white house back in 2024. byron let's
talk about this
i think it's going to be a massive red
wave i really do i think it's going to
be loud and clear we're going to win the
house we're going to win win back the
senate
but what are republicans going to do
when they're in power
what do you think are the first let's
say two or three
agenda items that you think they're
going to want to accomplish
look let me tell you the first one is
we're going to have to deal with border
security and i'm telling this is
different i want to lay this out for
everybody
you have immigration policy
that's
visas pathways into the country what do
you do about asylum procedures but then
you have border security you cannot have
a country when the drug cartels are
making 15 billion a year trafficking
people and trafficking fentanyl into the
united states so the number one thing we
got to do
[Music]
number one thing we got to do is and
when we start coming up with spending
bills that are going to come up under
house house republican control we have
to put in there hard and fast that joe
biden is not allowed
to spend money on allowing the cartel to
traffic people into the united states
that our border agents
have to have the ability to make
determinations of credible fear at the
border now what does that mean what that
means is the the real policy the
traditional policy has been border
agents can when somebody comes up they
can make a determination right then and
there is this person actually in fear of
their life in the country that they come
from and if they make a determination
that the answer is no the border agent
can turn around and send them right back
under joe biden they said oh no
that has to be an asylum judge
and that and that the person coming
across the country illegally gets an
attorney and that that's that proceeding
doesn't even start for six or seven
months and then the second hearing
doesn't start for six or seven years no
we got to stop all that house
republicans should do that just through
the budget the second thing we have to
get to
is in energy and what we have to do is
we have to make sure that this
administration
actually defends the oil leases and the
oil permits that they extend
the radical crazies
will give the permit but then they know
they got their buddies on the outside
who will sue
and they don't defend it in federal
court we have to demand that they defend
those permits in federal court because
if we're gonna be energy independent you
gotta let the people who are out there
busting their home drilling for oil and
drilling for gas they gotta have a fair
shot to get those holes a dug and get
that energy out to service the american
people and then we can actually get back
to even doing this cool thing which is
like exporting energy across the globe
so people aren't worried that aren't
reliant on putin or on gigi pain that's
what we need to be doing there's a
couple things we can get done oh and
don't don't meant i'm gonna let them
clap first finish clapping go that's
good stuff go
last one yes
we're gonna have a lot of investigations
y'all
a lot of investigations are coming
and we for once and for all are gonna
get down to the bottom of so many of the
problems that have been caused by
congressional democrats and by this
white house
because the american people need answers
and we have to get down to the solutions
that are going to put our country back
on track
so
[Laughter]
there's a there's a lot of opinions up
here lots of opinions but the uh
congressman let me ask you this because
i was quite shocked the other day when
joe biden kind of almost like said that
he handled covid better than president
trump did and i was like well but
president trump was working on operation
warp speed darling and but he's still
like he goes back to attacking president
trump
and and demonizing president trump and
then obviously any america first
politician
how is it going to work in a gridlock
environment when republicans are a
majority in the house and the senate and
you've got a democrat president well
it's going to be interesting to see how
it works but i think our charge mercedes
is to give him all he can deal with
let's see how big a boy he is
as far as being a veto president or one
that wants to move our country forward
because remember we get the house we get
the senate the people have spoken right
right and they want can they want
conservative leadership and he hopefully
he will see that and begin to sit down
and make a deal i'm in the car business
okay so i'm used to making deals
and uh
i just don't see that he will stand up
there alone and just veto everything
because as we've talked about you know
we've got a lot we've got a lot to fix
we've got to undo a lot of what he's
done and unfortunately he's driven by
what president trump did and so much of
what you know the good things that we
talk on the border title 42 is a good
thing right absolutely and mexico policy
is a good thing we need to keep all that
i've got a bill to make it permanent but
just because trump was for it and trump
created it he's against it so it's a
great question
and it may it may require some
brinkmanship it may require some
salesmanship
but at the same time he won't be tested
unless we as a house and we as a senate
get back to passing conservative
legislation that is for the people by
the people less lower taxes give give
the economy back to main street give the
economy back to consumers that that will
allow us all to compete for their
business instead of competing as against
the government so we got to get that
message out there we got to get that
legislation out there and let's just put
on his desk right
and let's see how let's see what he
wants to do byron you talked about
energy independence the critical
importance of this obviously we saw
president fighting go off to saudi
arabia begging for oil uh it really and
then you've got the bigger threat you've
got the the russia china iran
effect yes which is
they know they they know that if we keep
america we if they can keep america weak
that they're they're winning
so
how can republicans as we
take on these leadership roles push back
on china
push back on russia push back on iran
especially when you when you know that
what you're dealing with is a weak
president that hasn't been able to deal
with them well a couple of things one we
need to lead on ending this fuller's
foolishness with electric vehicles and
solar panels and wind farms this is
foolishness folks
it does not work
my good buddy roger's talking about
making a deal well what kind of deal
is it for us to take our treasure and
give it to china in exchange for
batteries that is dumb
that's just dumb stuff
yeah so what we need to do
is america we need to go back in time in
time a little bit and reinvigorate an
energy that we actually taught the world
how to create and that's nuclear power
we need to actually expand our nuclear
capabilities in the united states
we need to bring back the mining and
enrichment and enrichment of uranium and
even using thorium and molten salt
reactors here in the united states
instead of getting uranium from russia
which is where most of the world gets
their enriched uranium from we need to
do that here at home if you do that you
start taking care of your russia problem
if you stop getting all these batteries
and solar panels which by the way now we
know that the solar panels when you get
rid of them they actually leach into the
ground water and they contaminate
groundwater instead of doing that how
about we build our domestic energy
capacity here at home so it is cheap
it's reliable
oh and by the way folks that thing
nuclear power
it's actually greener than solar panels
it's greener than solar energy it's
greener
and it's readily available we can do
that
so that stops us sending money to the
chinese it stops us having to buy
uranium from the russians it puts us on
the capacity to lead the world when it
comes to expanding on nuclear innovation
it's amazing stuff i've been learning
this for the last year and a half it's
great stuff oil and natural gas we
should be exporting liquid natural gas
to europe to get europe off of the teats
of russia okay that's what we got to do
we should be exporting that to them we
can do that stuff
now how do you get this all to happen
you put pressure like roger was saying
on the current president of the united
states this man is terrible at his job
and
he's bad
he's terrible at his job and
he is so weak
that if house republicans and senate
republicans don't seize this moment to
put pressure on him and make him make
decisions then we have not done our job
so
as we're talking about solutions i think
one of the things has
one of the topics that keeps coming up
is is joe biden mentally fit to be
president no
no sorry i jumped the gun i apologize i
don't think any of his cabinet is
but he's not
i mean
when he's reading off the cue card and
he's like you should be seated now it's
like
what are they doing it's it's really bad
staff work let me ask you a question on
regulations because as we know
regulations plays a huge role
in if you're putting these burdens on
regulations on the energy industry on
this on businesses
it's it it's creates a huge huge havoc
in in investing in these businesses
what what do you think is and bring this
also not only the regulations piece but
the esg component that these
corporations are embracing left and
right
so regulations are killing small
business they're killing all businesses
here's an interesting statistic since
biden has come into office he's put 200
billion dollars worth of regulations on
small business
200 billion dollars
130 million hours is required
to deal with the 200 billion dollars in
regulations
president trump took all that away biden
has added that so if you're a bank or
you're a business
you're now all of a sudden finding this
sort of seems like a comedy show
as opposed to maybe a loan officer
that can do business you see so
the regulations and people don't think
about that but they literally choke
businesses and they cost jobs because
you have to hire people that are not
generate income for your business you
have to lay people off and so it's a
real disaster and they're going to
continue to put
put more and more uh out there for us so
uh that's what a challenge is and
and uh it's uh what they've done but if
you think of 200 billion uh dollars
sadly i can only stay until quarter of
at which point the the pizza man and
sean hannity were both supposed to have
spoken per the agenda and they're
running very behind hopefully we'll at
least get the pizza man
i'm in the car business
i'm in the car business for 51 years
nobody comes in and wants an ev vehicle
they don't ask for it and they have
forced these manufacturers to go woke
and they have gone for it i'm talking
about gm i'm talking about chrysler i'm
talking about ford all the others and
they've been into this and they're not
sellable they are not going to be
competitive i've said all along if you
live in texas you live right here and
you want to take a jet ski a boat or a
horse trailer to midland texas you're
never going to get there
and they want the government and they
want the government to put out the
charging stations when that ought to be
the job of the private sector like they
did with gas stations back in the 20s
and if we all know if if the government
owns it owns the charging stations
they're going to get vandalized they
won't work okay
so i'm just is the plan for the
government to own the charging stations
or just to subsidize them i hadn't heard
that the government was going to own the
charging station
then come let us make one okay but
consumers have to tell us what we want
as a dealer i need to sell what you want
not what the government wants you to
have so i'm pretty passionate imagine
complaining about gas prices and also
complaining about electric vehicles make
it but no government subsidies because
they're going to have to pay me to sell
it and they're going to have to pay the
manufacturer to make it and the
taxpayers in the end they're going to be
footing the bill it's a disaster so you
have an opinion
he has an opinion on electric vehicles
perfect tv ad i can see it now
uh byron you know we've seen the supply
honestly when people are just against
electric vehicles they sound so dumb
it's it's shocking it's almost like
it's almost like saying we really gotta
stay away from cars because the horses
and buggies are just so great
parents are
concerned what is going to be the
solution how do we handle this well look
i know pete buda judge when he went on
paternity leave you know he had some
baby formula
i know i know he might have had his
supply
look this is a real tragedy and the
reality is is that there are serious
reforms that have to be done at the fda
and this administration is not going to
do it
when you have a situation where parents
can't get baby formula like i used to
buy the baby formula in my house love
you honey but i did i went out and
bought it i know what it is i have to go
find the formula
and you have to keep the same formula
you can't switch yeah because the baby
will reject it right so when you do this
across the country and you don't have a
plan in place you have a situation where
children might have lower birth weight
both birth uh birth growth rates lower
brain development over the long term
this is a serious tragedy for infants
what you have to do is some serious
reforms at the fda they cannot shut down
plants without a pathway in order to
make sure the supply that is needed
continues if we had an administration
wasn't it a temporary shutdown because
there were like poisoned formula batches
i had a plan
they should stay open
and joe biden said this about three
years ago oh there was no plan there was
no plan
this guy is the guy with no plans we're
moving from crisis to crisis to crisis
it's going to take republican leadership
to make sure we have those quick point
on esg
esg
is fascism
that is what this stuff is it is fascism
when you have
knuckleheads in the bureaucracy who've
never run a business who've never really
had a real job and now they get to set
the standards for what societal goals
are what energy goals are they are no
better than the polar bureau esg is
environmental and social
governance i believe it's basically like
corporations should consider the
environmental and social impact of what
they do so we have bills
we there are bills in congress that
republicans are working on to get rid of
vsg we have bills actually i'm working
on i have a bill with uh my colleague
french hill from arkansas about getting
the full employment mandate out of the
federal reserve and getting the reserve
federal reserve back to just a stable
prices mandate so we don't have these
crazy inflations ripping through our
country those are the solutions that
we're working on
congressman what are we going to do
about big tech and censorship when
republicans take power
well i think we we need to go full speed
into it and we need to make sure voices
are heard and not and and not not heard
we've seen how they can control the
whole media operation and oh these
things you guys understand that
the other guy is like it's fascism to
tell businesses that they have to
consider the environmental and social
impact of their activities
and be because it's too much regulation
now this guy goes oh we've gotta ensure
that all of our opinions are heard on
social medias would uh which are private
companies do these people even realize
that they're parodies of themselves on
the same playing field and byron how do
we stop critical race theory from being
taught in our schools how do we stop
this crazy gender ideology oh god this
is a big problem that i don't think
parents would have ever imagined that
they would have to deal with no i listen
i know you know there's no way in hell
my mother would have allowed this to
happen
i'm telling you right now my mother
wouldn't have allowed this
oh okay
not her
meredith p brown no way this never would
have happened um
the biggest thing is and this is not
just federal this is federal state local
yes
you have to get with your county
commissions your school boards your
state legislatures and they need to make
sure that when they do these diversity
equity and inclusion seminars that every
government office does and a lot of
corporate offices are now doing that
they're not being run by these woke
non-profits that subscribe to critical
race theory that's how that stuff has
gotten into so many of our institutions
in the military one of the other key
things house republicans need to make
sure it gets done is that we are no
longer funding this woke ideology in our
military
our military men and women
our military men and women have one job
secure the nation and kill the enemy
when it's time to kill an enemy that is
their job no more no less
so that's what we got to do to get it
out together actually the military has
many other important things that they do
including as it relates to the
development of technology research i
mean
even that's very stupidly wrong fire
pelosi we're gonna we're gonna out vote
them in november right she's gonna be
gone okay
and it can't come soon enough but let me
tell you this is our generation's valley
forge i really believe this this really
is our most important election we are
here on this earth to save this country
right now
and we must fight this fight tell them i
had a football coach and college student
fighting bill fight them on the ice and
you fight until hell freezes over let's
go
but what i'm saying to you is this is
important and we've got to stand up and
we've got to understand this is
socialism don't be afraid of that word
it's not it's socialism it's fascism
it's all the above that's being
it's socialism and fascism liberty that
we have in this country this country is
over 200 years old as we all know and
look and it's it's done really well over
those period of time and look what how
how how
how hard it is to keep democracy what's
happened the last 18 months right it's
very precious we got to fight for it and
yesterday's gone forever tomorrow never
comes it's all about the present
and it's the present cause it's a gift
from god this is our gift to stand up
say we're not taking it anymore we love
our country america is the greatest
country in the world let's keep it that
way
all right you got to try to beat that
you got me ready to suit up coach
hope she got me ready to suit up
listen this is very simple you got to
get out and vote and you better get your
family out to vote and you better get
your friends out to vote
we are watching halfway around the
around the globe the ukrainian people
are staring the russian military in the
face because they want to defend their
sovereignty and they're not worried
about it not being fair they're not
worried about how the russians got more
equipment they're fighting and they're
laying everything on the line to defend
their country if they're willing to do
that here in the united states the least
we can do is show up and vote so let's
show up and vote let's get rid of pelosi
let's take back the house and let's save
america that's it
all right
good job
okay so our final c pack
handshake
one two three
whoa
congressman byron donald's congressman
roger williams thank you both so much
and let's do this
[Applause]
oh god uh this is not safe for children
um okay i think papa john is next and
then i i actually have to run at about
15 because i have a prior commitment but
let's see if we can see it uh this is
really bad really really bad
i think my granddad bought a buick from
this guy okay yeah that guy was quite a
character a thank you to scarecrow crow
humanoid hersafat
and joe sauce for the twitch prime
subscription
the heck was that did you see that i
don't even how long was that playing i
didn't even know what that was could you
guys hear me i don't know where that
came from that was bizarre
10 seconds
oh my god
anyway i was thanking people
um
please sign up folks please sign up at
joinpakman.com use the coupon code
indict
welcome to johnnybob number 61 today via
twitch prime i also thanked someone
through the website that was what it was
uh that's what it was all about
how do these guys have the hutzpah to
tell these lies about electric vehicles
and energy politics these guys are
either unintelligent or narcissists who
don't care what happens to our planet
why not both
i think that they're actually both to be
perfectly frank
uh oh my god a lot of very strange
videos happening here
very very strange videos
um yeah they're they are obsessed with
lying about electric vehicles they just
absolutely
hate them
what is this tusk the free speech
browser
i haven't seen this they've got
they have a free speech everything it
seems like they have their free speech
uh platform
hold on do i have that truth essential
and now they have a free speech browser
as well
parlor
parlor is a very important thing
wow this is this is truly cuckoo
cuckoo for cocoa puffs thank you to tim
silver bonito
who has just gifted a subscription at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 62 today
we are standing by for papa john
schnatter
and we have a couple other voicemails
that have come in
hey dave loves show uh i've got a
serious question for you at what point
do
the authorities all right hold on it's
papa john let's listen
[Music]
ah good
afternoon thanks man thanks mercedes
thank all of you all for your courage to
be here i think it's outstanding
um
who loves pizza
mexico yeah who loves freedom
obama
well for freedom wouldn't be no pizza it
wouldn't be no papa john's that's for
sure but
anyway i read that if not for freedom we
would have no pasta either
gas prices
interest rates going through the roof
we're weak on the foreign front
[Music]
and what i'm referring to
is the 1970s
um jimmy carter there you go ford
um
not the 2020s um
someone's really got to tell this guy
you got to wear a v-neck undershirt i
mean this is just not a good look how
has he not look at the money this guy
has and he's wearing a crew neck
undershirt
is my father
was a
serial entrepreneur and he got to the uk
school selling hot dogs on hot dogs and
so he was an entrepreneur and he had
six businesses in the seventies and they
all went back bankrupt yeah
high regulation high fuel
uh anti-business and attitude against
the entrepreneur
and
the toll it took on me to this day the
scarring
was just immense
and um
all of a sudden you know we had to live
with this every day and you can't really
have empathy for anybody unless you've
walked a mile in their shoot i don't
know if any of you have ever been
bankrupt or had you know kind of been in
the rope it's it's the worst feeling in
the world
and we live that uh in the 70s
and i look at the poor entrepreneurs
today in the 2020s
and i reflect back on just what they
have to deal with with
yeah regulation printing of money
inflation but we have a mindset
from a commander-in-chief
who's really
anti-entrepreneur and entrepreneurship
is not the thing entrepreneurship is
everything everything we have
in america in the capitalistic system
starts with an entrepreneur really an
electric speaker creativity it's a
better more efficient way to do
something
then all of a sudden 1980 comes along
and what's the saying is that
if you don't learn from history repeat
the mistakes i would argue that
the key is to learn from history and
don't repeat those mistakes
and reagan comes along
he's pro-business he's pro-entrepreneur
uh entrepreneur he's
um
lowers rates by half
takes inflation down uh half
um fuel prices drop
and all of a sudden we have this magical
time as he called it
the shining city on the hill
or reagan's nine
words that were the most dangerous words
in the english language
i'm from the government
and i'm here to help
um
you know the guy got the joke i mean he
was he was a superstar then
um
papa john's that's what we came up we're
in a broom closet we got 1600 bucks
and we had a dream of making a better
pizza right and
i mean
the tailwind we had by having leadership
and having an economy
um and having pro entrepreneur and
pro-business mindset how lucky was i
here i am
you know
in a brew closet my dad's tavern
and we had sixteen hundred dollars end
up building five thousand stores we're
doing four billion a year but we thought
we could do it because we were in an
environment
that we could do it
and i just felt so lucky and fortunate
to be in the environment i was in the
80s
versus today in the environment that my
dad was in the 70s
the
the pizza is a disaster folks have a
linear equation i call it
the evil elite left
uh
gates
um
sores
zoraz
swab i mean swab guys
soras and swab are the guys that are
going to destroy the country
the pharmaceutical are the processed
foods processed food that the fda fda
shouldn't really approve
it doesn't kill you but it really does
make you sick
and then
the same five groups that own the
processed foods
also own
the pharmaceutical companies that they
get you on because they're not sick
so there's five entities that really
control
media academia and everything else
soras it's those five evil entities you
can always tell
when they're active
um
and what they're doing
um it goes back to 1918
the frankfurt institute
where um
the concept was
fascism marxianism
but bachelor's degree destroyed disrupt
disrupt disrupt um without any any
solution
uh they start out in the forties where
they attacked the middle class
60s and 70s with the
uh sex
revolution
uh the culture in the 90s and 2000 yep
and now they're attacking our youth
um
whether it's sex trafficking on the
border illegal drugs coming through the
border
um
the
crt
vaccines to five month olds or
five-year-olds everything they they do
they're trying to disrupt their youth
because vaccines are disruptive if
you're going to create a global
economy
you've you've got to have america to
participate
and the only way america is going to
participate
is where if we're discombobuled or we're
in disarray we're in a position of
weakness
and
the
evil forces at the top because it is a
battle now
between good and evil
is
that we must protect our youth our youth
is our future our children our future
and they know that
and our our children
are under attack
yikes so
i
end this with a little bit of
a note okay what's the solution you have
this
linear tug of war they throw a dart a
missile with all the missile back
um you take something like the left
wants security
uh the right this is one of the funniest
and saddest things i've ever seen that's
just one aspect of what we fight over
and then the government puts in bad
policy right down the middle it doesn't
really solve the problem and and i would
argue
that
we have the right ideology we have
truth in god
free markets
free enterprise
which enhances
the betterment of humanity we have that
on our side
that's a good thing but i think if we're
going to change the world this is sadder
than mike pillow i agree uh you know not
only what we say it's not what we do
it's who we become
as a nation data work can never be small
if the inner work is great
and that a word could never be great if
the inner work
is small
the tug of war
is a very
low
vibration low
frequency
game
that it's it's it's a pluses it's a it's
a game that they're going to win because
of numbers
a higher vibration game
one of joy
compassion
kindness
enlightenment um
that's a game when we increase yeah
folks if anybody in the audience needs a
mercy ban just ask the moderators i
would understand it i do back vibration
and we increase our
our party
then we can together can change the
world
and i know we have to fight the good
fight i have i have liberal friends
i love them they think like buffoons
um
they think arithmetic's an opinion
um they're full of anger they ask them
are you angry because you're stupid are
you stupid because you're angry
hmm
these sound like great friends the
answer is the latter
they're stupid cause they're angry
they're there's a jealousy aspect a
hatred
um
[Music]
envy shame guilt aspect that keeps them
from functioning at a higher level of
rationality this guy needs to take
public public speaking advice from
herschel walker the level of awareness
and so if we want to increase
awareness
if we want to be a tractor like reagan
mother teresa
gandhi
jesus i mean muhammad buddha if we want
to be a tractor we have to change
ourselves
you know as a goof it's occurring to me
i just looked and there's
there's a papa john's in brooklyn
that would actually deliver to the
studio
i wonder if tomorrow night during the
trump rally i should somehow allow the
audience to configure a papa john's
pizza and to get it delivered during the
stream would that be so i mean i don't
know would that even be interesting as a
group
on your side it's gotten true
those are the two strongest characters
you can have don't do it all right
you combine that with awareness and a
consciousness to really see and
understand right would i eat it is the
key question i certainly don't want to
support the business and i don't know
that i would eat it we will keep that
light on
on that shining city on top of the hill
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
did he just make a weird noise did you
guys hear that
was that him that was a really strange
noise that he just made
maybe that's a speech impediment of some
kind which i would never make fun of it
was just very very strange i've never
seen that before
um
[Music]
wow
wow
that was
that was really weird
it was
it was the start of the n-word and he
was holding it in yeah that's very
clever very very clever all right guys
well that ends my coverage today they
only have a couple more speakers
and i'm going to be back tomorrow okay
maybe we'll order a papa john's pizza
for delivery or whatever the case may be
i appreciate everybody joining me make
sure you're following on twitch make
sure you have subscribed on youtube it's
all free so that tomorrow we can all
meet here again
um
under the auspices of glory and
everything
um this is texas lieutenant governor dan
patrick and he's absolutely bonkers
definitely a bit of a uh
well anyway i'm not going to comment on
his physical appearance that would be
outside the scope but we will see
everybody tomorrow thank you very much
you